[Musique]
bonjour la réunion bonjour le monde
entier comment a t'il et si ça devait
bien
ben moi mal et mieux marmaille alors
aujourd'hui où ça nourrit aujourd'hui on
est à l'ermitage dans l'ouest de la
réunion sur la côte
il fait beau et qu'est ce qu'on fait à
l'ermitage et bien tout simplement on va
voir michael michael qui est souffleur
de verre louis braille
c'est un métier ont quand même un peu
rare il faut bien donc à revoir ça tout
de suite
mais bon vieillotte allez venez venez
venez là suivez moi votre humble
serviteur venez venez
[Musique]
bonjour michael salle couverte allez
vous ça va super bien ce matin il fait
beau il fait beau il fait super c'est
juste génial
dis moi où ça nous les alors et qu'est
ce que tu fais où on est on est à
l'ermitage l'a donc moi je suis
souffleur de verre
voilà donc bah je travaille le verre
soufflé à chaud donc on fait fondre du
verre pour le travail est battu c'est
quoi moi j'ai envie de voir ça de suite
j'ai envie parce que moi je suis un
groupe curieux et curieuses
[Musique]
voilà donc là on est dans mon atelier là
un petit peu tous donc c'est ici qu'on
travaille le verre
donc on peut travailler le verre sous
plein de formes se plaint de façon moi
je suis souffleur de verre avant tout
voilà hier qu'on fait fond du verre dans
un four principalement et ensuite on va
le trail est donc soit à la main on va
souffler dedans avec des cannes des
outils ou alors on travaille à la can au
bo chalumeau on peut faire n'importe
quoi on peut faire des petites pièces
des petits dos des petits personnages
des petits bijoux des petits pendentifs
là c'est pour les tout petits sujets
pour les grosses pièces on va s'attaquer
au four là bas avec un gros four de
fusion dans lequel on peut faire fondre
une centaine de kilos de verre d'accord
quand tu diverses et toute forme de v à
jeudi à exemple chez page et cinquante
pots de moutarde ou je sais pas quoi
anvers alors tu peux les faire fondre
pourrais-je pourrait éventuellement
effectivement les faire fondre mais faut
savoir qu'il ya différents types de
verres ils ont chacun leur composition
et donc nous on va les sélectionnés par
rapport à notre travail nous on est des
artisans travaillent à la main on a
besoin que le verre soit plus ou moins
tendre et peut-être contré à un tueur un
tube comme ça comment ça se passe
moi je les reçois ils sont comme ça
voilà donc là on a un tube transparent
complètement transparent qui fait un
mètre cinquante où un médecin est de
taille c'est taille standard
ça c'est un tube blanc il existe noir
ils existent en nombre il existe rouge
il existe bleus ont choisi toutes les
couleurs on a tous les diamètres on a
toutes les épaisseurs et selon la pièce
qu'on va réaliser
on va sélectionner un morceau du
cylindre fait c'est les pédales vadot
mais ben voila quoi il ya plus de
courant il ya des fois c'est ça ouais
tout et pas à lui mais là en fait
effectivement donc on a le gros four de
fusion juste devant toi la grosse brique
blanche
donc ça c'est un faux que j'ai fait
moi-même ouais c'est pas très droit mais
ça tient bien ça chauffe bien c'est ce
qui compte c'est un gros gros four c'est
du réfractaire tout simplement on envoie
du gaz par le dessus avec un brûleur
spéciale et on obtient une température
de 1200 degrés dont je peux te montrer
l'intérieur parce que justement là tu
vas pouvoir en profiter pour une fois qu
un fourré et un devoir l'intérieur c'est
pas courant
peu voire même qui reste un peu de vert
au fond il faut 24 heures pour faire
monter à 12 100 degrés et il me faut
encore 24 heures pour faire fondre le
verre et en plus auparavant enfin c'est
40 48 heures juste voilà juste
d'attentes d'attentes avant de pouvoir
commencer à travailler et adam vraiment
tu vois j'ai une canne à souffler ça
c'est un tube en faire donc on a le goût
qui est un petit peu plus épais pour
pouvoir résister à la chaleur et c'est
celui qui nous cherchent qui nous sert à
aller chercher justement le vert dans le
bassin donc à la manière d'une cuillère
on va piquer dedans on va tourner tout
en faisant la cuillère pour aller
chercher une petite noix de verre en
fusion et cette petite noix de verre en
fusion on peut en soufflant par ici
créer une goutte et comme une goutte de
miel
si on la laisse couler un peu elle va
tomber et on va avoir la forme d'un vase
simplement donc on va utiliser beaucoup
beaucoup
l'inertie là ce qu'on appelle la
pesanteur présent en fait donc on a deux
outils de travail la force centrifuge et
les pesanteurs et on va jouer avec ces
deux outils pour leur donner des formes
on peut pas mettre la pizza dedans on
peut pas mettre le poulet de dans
marianne fait très attention et c'est
vraiment pour le verre le poulet le
poulet cuit en 0 50 secondes voilà +10
50 secondes et un mangeable nous revoilà
l'endroit où tu travailles toute la
création du génie de la création où les
murs pas jusque là mais c'est vrai qu'on
va tous se passe ici hein c'est vrai que
voilà plus en plus nous quand on fait de
la création souvent c'est un petit peu
instinctif c'est sûr l'envi sur le
moment injustement dix mois que l'agent
de pièces tu fais tu fais des naylor
pendentif 10 min alors ben là au
chalumeau on pourrait faire un petit
pendentif mais bon pour pour l'image et
pour la caméra on va faire quelque chose
d'un petit peu plus gros pour ce qu'elle
voit que vous voyez un petit peu comment
ça se passe aussi sur le soufflage là je
vais souffler une baleine je vais faire
une baleine en verre soufflé voilà donc
donc ça va me faudra être beaucoup dire
ça va paraître simple il faut pas
énormément d'air vous allez voir il faut
pas énormément d'air imagine la bulle de
chewing gum tu te souviens de la bulle
de chewing gum c'est un peu pareil si tu
souffle trop fort dans ta bulle de
chewing gum elle pète le vert c'est
pareil alors il va pas péter il explose
pas mais pareil pour ça fait un petit
trou et puis il se rabougrit et voilà
donc là il faudrait faire attention il
va falloir gérer le falloir gérer le
souffle gérer la température tout se
passe dans la main et dans l'oeil donc
là on a le chalumeau redon gaz
c'est simplement voilà donc là on a une
flamme n'est pas suffisamment forte pour
faire fondre le vert là tout ce qu'elle
va faire c'est le faire noircir un petit
peu donc nous ont obligés de rajouter de
l'oxygène donc j'ai des machines
spécifiques pour ça ah ouais la flamme
change du règne de couleurs de voilà
grâce à l'oxygène pur de l'oxygène en
fait on obtient une flamme qui va monter
à pas loin de 1400 dollars c'est
largement suffisant pour pouvoir
travailler
donc on va préchauffé doucement le tube
le vert il aime pas du tout les chocs
thermiques
je rentre tout de suite dans la flamme
comme ça ils risquent de casser faut
jouer les doucement en hautes flammes
commençaient à préchauffer voilà donc là
maintenant que le vert à commencer à
bien chauffer on voit il a rougi un
petit peu il ya rosé clair maintenant je
vais pouvoir commencer à le travailler
comment j'ai de moulins allez les
moulins avec ma palette par exemple je
peux commencer à rétrécir un peu donc on
tourne en permanence de manière à
chauffer régulièrement la surface pour
concerner une chauffe bien homogène toi
là il va vers le bas donc moi on tourne
en jeu l'empêchent de tomber pour rester
dans son axe de symétrie
[Musique]
alors on va mettre ses lunettes
pour bien voir en fait l'effet du fait
sur le vert parce qu'en fait c'est jaune
on voit rien avec ça je vais tout voir
aux yeux pour la ramener un peu plus
régulière je vais venir si c'est
légèrement la chose au bout voilà non
non moi mon oeil juge du mouvement et de
la couleur du vert j'estime que c'est
plus ou moins cher
[Musique]
j'ai plus besoin de ça
alors tout va se jouer maintenant avec
des outils
[Musique]
placez travail d'écriture c'est assez
long
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
voilà
sept baleines je vais les mettre au four
maintenant qu'elle est finie on va là
recueillir dans un four pourquoi donc là
j'ai un four qui a 500 degrés je vais la
mettre dedans c'est pour l'adoucir c'est
pourquoi alors là c'est pour justement
enlever les chocs thermiques d'accord
parce que pendant le travail
j'ai chauffaient beaucoup derrière et
pas de vent et un beau milieu il ya eu
un choc thermique qui risque qu'un
joueur va te casser
donc moi je la mets au four et donc le
lv restée 12 heures 12 heures 12 heures
donc moi toute la journée je vais
travailler je vais remplir le four et ce
soir je vais le coupé et il va descendre
doucement doucement en température
pendant toute la nuit et seulement
demain vous pourrez sortir mes pièces
alors mes canons mais dans ta petite
boutique avaient toutes des oeuvres
toutes tes avant tout cas tu peux tout
ce qu'on fait ici ouais voilà c'est un
petit peu tout ce qu'on peut réaliser
envers ces différentes techniques ou
forme ça donne une idée voir un petit
peu tout ce qu'on fait et tu me disais
que tu prépares concours parce qu'il
faut pas que tu partes secret ça il faut
le dire aux gens c'est pas ce secret
c'est sûr que bon voilà on engage
préparera le concours effectivement du
meilleur ouvrier de france sur la
technique du presse-papier une technique
bien particulière voilà qui consiste à
réaliser un décor bien précis dans une
boule de cristal donc
donc voilà donc ce n'est pas fait on
s'entraîne on travaille dur tous les
jours
le résultat commence à entrer doucement
donc c on verra comment ça se passe
comment temps est venu à travailler le
verre est ce que ça a été pour toi tu te
réveilles tu dis je vais les faits un
nom s'est dit un peu le hasard en fait
j'en ai amené à devenir verrière je suis
originaire d'auvergne et il ya en
auvergne à un lycée collège qui apprend
à passer à ses capés de souffleur de
verre et de tailleur sur verre aussi par
la même occasion qu'il a ça a été la
révélation quand on m'a ouvert les
portes de l'atelier j'ai vu les fours
avec le verre en fusion à l'intérieur ça
a été qu'une envie c'est d'aller
chercher la matière pour travailler et
après la passion a pris le dessus et du
coup un sortie de mons et ap je savais
pas trop quoi faire
on m'a dit qu'il y avait des
cristalleries qui embauchent et
saint-louis d'hommes la ligue baccarat
les grandes cristallerie dans l'est de
la france donc je suis parti là-bas et
puis ben j'ai acquis rien j'ai acquis un
savoir faire au bout de 6 7 ans quand
même et après j'ai décidé moi de partir
et de m'installer à mon compte il m'a
fallu quand même
6 7 ans dans les cristalleries pour
aller chercher ce savoir faire qui ne
s'improvise pas bravo à toi et ben les
jeunes savez ce qu'il vous reste à faire
renseignez-vous passer me voir voilà un
mais jamais un vieux aussi voilà si on
n'a pas tout dit voilà les jeunes les
vieux les tontons les tati tout le monde
quoi tout de même se faire plaisir voilà
salut mon coffre
à bientôt à la prochaine on revoit tout
le monde nous retrouverons en asie
[Musique]
l'émission se termine mal oui oui il
faut il faut une fin tout c'est comme ça
voilà on s'est arrêté lé mitage c'est
beau il fait chaud
comment vous dire en fait je vais tout
simplement vous laisser est allé picanto
peut-être là ouais ouais ouais
ne pas oublier on n'est pas du tout
sorti de l'auberge
promis juré on n'est pas sorti de
l'auberge mais moi je crois je vais
rentrer dans l'eau à plus tard
[Musique]